as pride month continues so are the
various ways businesses are celebrating
founders coffee has a new drink
especially for pride month that also
raises money for a great local cause
here to talk about that we have bronwyn
cora and susie newman from founders
coffee thank you both for being here
how'd you come up with the idea well
first of all you do every month you have
a giving drink is that right yes
every month and so various causes and
obviously with this being pride month it
made sense so the beneficiary this month
is whom the center the center okay which
is in downtown area
great things it does for the community
yes and how did you come up with the
drink
we like to come up with something fun
every month that's kind of our chance to
break away from our normal menu and do
something fun and exciting so
what more fun during pride month to do
something really colorful
yup so susie came up with the flavors
yes fruity pebbles i'm you already had
me right away i love fruity pebbles
let's make one okay so we have
marshmallow syrup okay start with that
okay how many pumps three or four pumps
okay yeah
oh you're good i got you i'm so sorry
yeah
all right then you have your espresso
here
okay then you've got milk
how much
to the top
the whipped cream is the most dangerous
part
okay okay you can give it a little stir
we have a straw there okay yeah how am i
doing am i hired you're doing great yeah
the speed is perfect yeah that's pretty
good
nice okay you may see me at founders you
have two locations so there's two places
i could work uh saint rose or durango
right we are hiring yeah yeah okay good
i got i've got it
all right
strawberry banana whipped cream now when
you um when you do this just be careful
go slow yep okay don't try this at home
is that what we're saying upside down
okay there we go
nice
oh splatter
there we go oh yeah you probably don't
do it that tall do you no that's fine
okay okay and then we have fruity
pebbles
sprinkles pebbles sprinkle and boom
all right
this is great i love this drink and it's
called what again the fruity pebble
latte okay so just remember fruity
pebbles so if you go to one of the
locations you ask for this and then one
dollar from every drink goes to the
center yes for this month yeah so next
month will be a different drink and a
different charity and we just kind of
keep going every month with something
new
how long has founders coffee been around
now
we are gonna have two through almost
three years in november so we opened one
location uh almost three years ago the
second location we opened in the middle
of the pandemic
and it's coming on two years ago holy
cow how'd that go initially really good
have the local community come and
support us and continue to order through
the drive-through it's been really great
for our team and for the company you
have a way people can order online too
we do yeah third-party delivery ubereats
postmates all of that and then right on
our website founders coffee co you can
order a head and pick it up in the
drive-through fruity pebble espresso
i think i just renamed it what was it
you said fruity pebble latte latte
okay you got it at founders at either
durango st rose thank you guys so much
it's a great cause too really appreciate
it all right let's check in with jc and
see what he's up to